salut c'est Hugo cette semaine je
voulais vous partager marave un
documentaire de Cyril domanico marave ça
veut dire bagarre en gitant la box c'est
super important dans la communauté ça se
transmet de génération en génération
dans ce doc on suit trois personnages
assez dingue ange Bryan et Jordi ange
c'est l'enfant précoce de la boxe poussé
par son père Bryan c'est le bagarur et
Jordi c'est le professionnel trois
destins qui s'inspirent de Tyson Fury le
Gypsy King champion du monde des poids
lourds
[Applaudissements]
la flamme du gitan ne s'a
jamais
les
anciens au bord du feu le soir il bu un
coup Racon les histoire de bagarre qu'
pouv faire
quoi qu'ils ont fait qu'ils ont vécu et
nous les éc rest des HE à les écouter
parler je mappelle BR j'ai 28 ans je
parti de la communauté g du voyage pour
nous l'avantage c'est d'être libre la
sensation de liberté to demain si je
veux j'accroche ma Caravan je men vais
je à 500 km 1000 km bout de la
terre
pour un oui ou pour un
non ça peut partir vois il me clxonne il
fait l'homme il me fait des doigts
n'importe quoi moi je tire le fr à main
je sors dehors qu'est-ce qu'il y a je
fous une droite à travers gar
terminé je fais des combats un peu
illégal entre guillemets
quoi ça m'a pris d'un coup comme ça ça
faisait 4 ans que j'avais pas mis les
gants et tout je suis parti là-bas j'éta
me Batt à ma nu j'ai fait ce que j'avais
à faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il m'a eu sur un compte c'est comme ça
j'ai une nique là en ce moment tu vois
je m'entraîne je m'entraîne je lâche
rien je lâche rien je me relève toujours
tu
vois j'ai pas eu le temps de montrer ce
que je
voulais
je travaille parce que j'ai pas le choix
sinon je ser pas
là franchement ça me vide le cerveau moi
je suis quelqu'un d'ASS hyper actif
sinon je des câbles
carrment est des bseurs rien tu ve
manger
trava parce que les gens comprennent pas
gens du voyage ils sont en caravane
c'est des étrangers ils ont rien à faire
en France on est français plus que des
fois c'est
vrai mais tu vois j'ai pris ça pour moi
là c'est le panneau normalement que
c'est l'air d'accueil des gens du voyage
je l' enlevé je tiré deux trois coups de
fusil dedans je l'ai enlevé parce que
c'est chez moi maintenant tu vois c'est
mon terrain privé maintenant et si les
gens ils veulent venir ils pevent ir il
Esser pas rest longtemp je
pense ah ouantenne il nous ont mis
anenne c'est quoi 4G
5G pour nous du coup n m là personne
sont cont je pense je pense que c'est
comme ça et toutes les places que j'ai
fait j'étais sur Lyon tout ça cétait
exactement pareil
déchterie
cimetière sortie de la ville direction
la déchterie trouv une c'est chez moi
c'est là où je vis ma caravane est là
tiens tiens manger tu bon pour ma petite
ça c'est bon c'est bon quoi tu as soif
peut-être non
tiens ma petite chouette ah la caméra ça
dérange
[Musique]
CR devant la caméra tu vois pas c'est
c'est une star
c'est c'est bon pe filmer la Campine oui
TI vas-y prends
là r
rentre maintenant je suis père de
famille j'ai les enfants
tout je peux pas avoir de problème avec
la justice tout ça je suis je suis
tranquille chez moi faut que je m'occupe
de de mes affaires quoi la bagarre te
manquait quoi la bagarre me manquait
c'est ce qui me manquait je voulais
retrouver cette sensation de se
battre quand j'allais là-bas je savais
les risques que je prenais c'était soit
je gagne je perd en plus face caméra
donc je prenais le risque je m'en
foutais
il est où il est
[Applaudissements]
où j'étais trop sûr de moi déjà j' trop
sûr de moi j' Allis trop sin et ça m'a
fait redescendre dans
[Applaudissements]
l'étage chez nous c'est tu prends tu
perds tu vois c'est c'est pas pareil
vois tu as pris un coup dans ta fierté
hein moi j'ai jamais perdu un combat
jamais tu ta tête jamaisas juste besoin
d'
le que j'ai pris ça m'a pesé mais bon je
me relève plus fort pour moi c'est rien
je rigole maintenant la vidéo je
rigole
com mon prochain combat je veux qu'il VO
quelqu'un vraiment
[Applaudissements]
sère
P mon surnom c'est mon hom de
forain mon pauvre père éit
boxeur je me suis retrouvé à 6 ans et
demi sans
père toute ma vie j'ai toujours voulu
prendre l'exemple de mon
père j'ai perdu ma
femme
j'ai plus aucun plaisir le se plaisir
c'est ça c'est la
BO et là je petit ça me fait une
[Applaudissements]
sortie
je va aller tout ouvrir alors maouille
comment tu vas ça va un bon petit tu
m'aime bien m'appelle pasou il sattach à
moi
et besoin de moi un bisou
PAP ça va tuas pas mis la chaîne je veux
donner tout mon savoirfaire si j'arrive
à le pousser à le tenir faire quelquun
de bien je peux partir après
tranquille pour faire quoi
dit que cétait pour ta
box n'importe quoi c'est pas ton
gros
[Musique]
filme-moi elle cuisine extérieure de ma
femme elle belle alors c'est
cuisine alors un
garde et oui
monouille ça sert à rien vite c'est pas
bon vous donne un cou revenir au bras
are cou revenir au bras vite vite c'est
pas des bons coups tu tes pas là tu
chatouill le sac allez vas-y droite
gauche et tu fais revenir ton bas de
suite allez
voilà allez C il y en a naissent pour
voler il y en a qui naissent pour tuer
nous on est on est pour se défendre se
faire respecter tu prends des castagnes
pas la boxe c'est moi qui va défoncer
tu'en prends des castagnes ouais je
m'appelle Michel
Lauro je suis le papa de H c'est vrai je
suis bagareur souvent il me voit
toujours quoi si je canalise pas
maintenant il va faire pour moi il te
faut une retenue et ça la box ça me
plaît ça ça t'empêche de faire plein de
bêtises voilà non avec les PO voilà mon
cousin dans le sac à la RAF
là regarde il pas beau celui-là jazz il
s'appelle jazz
ils viennent de tour c'est des morouche
on est tous les deux ou pas tu ses taper
dans le sac vas-y taper dans le sac
vas-y montre-ous comment
tu vas-y droite ga ta tête un peu tuas
pas la
en non di regarde regarde comment il
faut faire tu fais ça ça ça ça ça ça ça
ça
voilà la garde reviens la garde reviens
la garde le sac qui vient vers
toi quand je voyageais encore il a il y
a 3 4 ans on arrivait on se pétait sur
des stades et c'est souvent qu'il
fallait apprendre à ouais ça ça à se
défendre c'est a des gens ça leur
plaisait pas qu'on s'y mette même les
gendarmes pas gendérir te
défendre c'est pas le fou j'e
bien c'est tout
moi carère tu champion mais fait du vélo
ou quoi que ce soit d'autre mais bi il
est pour la Boxe champion à la box je
suis meilleur il y a personne qui pas
jamais le meilleur il toujours plus fort
que
Jord je suis boxeur
professionnelant mon adversaire dor moi
je
m'entraî pourre F ma famille et puis et
puis montrer aussi que che les gens du
voyage on peut avoir de grands
champions c'est pour atteindre mon but
d'être champion du monde
si je suis là aujourd'hui à 28 combats
28 victoires c'est que j'ai un
truc mais le truc c'est le sérieux et
l'envie surtout l'envie de voilà de
réussir et de montrer que chez nous les
gitans bah on peut faire aussi quelque
chose de
[Applaudissements]
bien là on va chercher le
cheval pour le nourrir et puis pour
s'occuper un peu de un peu de lui on
aime tellement les les chevau que il en
faut toujours un avec nous à côté avec
le papa bah et là on va le prendre c'est
ça en occupation aussi à lui voilà il
est un peu curieux
là
viens viens mon gars viens et ben c'est
une grande patience et là on le caresse
ça y est il
est là il est heureux et ben on a
toujours eu des chevud quoi puis le
grandpère puis ainsi de suite ça l'
toujours été les roulottes les chevau on
a grandi que ça quoi bah c'est vraiment
une culture chez nous les chevau c'est
ce qui nous permettait avant aussi de de
voyager de de de ville en ville donc oui
c'est vraiment important avec la boxe on
va dire que c'est un un gros
5050 alle
alle je l'ai acheté un copain quoi c'est
un ridicche son père il a gagné le Prix
d'Amérique comme ça va pas assez vite B
il est mettre à la casse pourquoi vous
voulez sauver des chemx mais pour pas le
pour pas le faire tuer non j'ai horreur
de
ça tu fais quoi comme manger maman parce
qu'elle a un
peu le
feu bah c'est ma grand-mère tante et ma
maman ma maman qui stresse beaucoup
quand je boxe ben nous aussi la tante
aussi qui me supporte beaucoup j'entends
derrière vas-y mon Ve comme elle était
plus jeune ma mère a boxer avec des avec
des gars à mter les gants je peux durer
que c'est la vérité à
boxer et boxé encore F box avec les
garçons et tout m lesgant puis boxé avec
avec ses fr ses qu elle était plus jeune
bien sûr
oui cette famille c'est ça ça pas en
fait c'est
ça
tiens ça c'est Jordi là il était
champion de France tu avais quel âge là
Jordy 89 ans où les boxeurs rêvent
d'être champion du monde il faut avoir
une grosse volonté mais il là
Jord il fait tout pour être champion du
monde ça c'est
moi Joseph le Giton c'est marqué ouais
ah il est très modeste il est un peu et
il a fait quelques Combas en amateur et
c'est pour ça qu' aussi moi j'ai aimé la
boxe parce que je voyais tout petit ses
ses cassettes et je voulais faire un
sport de combat il m'a fait taper dans
ses mains après il m'a emmelé dans la
salle où il a boxé puis depuis bah avec
les chevaux et la boxe on a jamais on a
jamais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lâché
as fait
lait quoi la
Guer
alle maman m'a pas coiffé la maman là
t'inquiète pas
allez
tous les matins on va au
marché et tous les matins on se lève on
fait un tour chacune faut qu'on fasse
quelque chose de notre vie alors du coup
on se lève tôt et puis on va travailler
avec eux du coup on fait les les cours
par correspondance
maintenant allez c'est
parti allez les vous allez allez allez
NZ pas faire prochain pret que frais
allez les poul faire 10 allez allez
12 allez fais-moi des
Barquet al remz-moi les légumes les
filles j'apprends à leur
parler j'apprends la poitess j'apprends
tout allez petit alle petit
pour si si il va
l'école il est part tout le attends mais
il y va parceil y a le covid et tout
c'est
dangereux mais j'aime bien qu' qu'il y a
quand même tu vois je veux au moins
qu'il apprenne lire écrire et compter tu
sais mais le la base moi je sais pas
écrire je lis je vais lire tout
doucement tranquillement mais je je et
pourquoi tu veux que lui il apprenne ah
c'est un handicap et je veux
qu'il aille à l'école qu'il apprenne ça
allez viens ici je veux pas te voir
derrière là-bas allô je veux te voir
devant il y a du monde tu restes à côté
de bonjour les r pour ce midi c'est
l'école de la vie là tu apprends tout tu
apprends à dire bonjour tu apprends la
politesse tu apprends le respect co ciao
tu apprends à gagner et il apprend là où
j'ai
appris merci Monsieur bonne journée et
un garçon dans le r pas
dez il me voit galérer tout l'hiver il
sait qu'il faut faut y aller pour avoir
quelque chose sera pare pour la boxe il
la prend maintenant tu
vois
c'est qui
luion commenton fur il D avec moi tu
sais mon gros
bébé il dort avec moi du coup tous les
soirs il me dit on va dans le lit un peu
il me dit non comme ça on se regarde les
vidéos de Tyson Fury Tyon Fury c'est
c'est son seom c'est Gpsy Gpsy King
c'est le roi des des gitans à la BO
c'est le meilleur tu imagines parce que
déjà être le meilleur des boxeurs c'est
une chose et après le meilleur des
voyageurs parce que chez les voyageurs
là-bas ça tape tu trouves comment an
fort
grand tu aimerais aller le voir il
faudrait que je l'amène dans un un
combat tu vois mais de de niveau faut
qu'il ait C cette odeur
de de de ring de des gens qui crient des
ouais mais là qu'est-ce que c'est qu'il
fait pas là quand tu le regardes
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'il a pas làe
allez fais voir ta souplesse un
peu encore encore encore encore lâche
tes mains enlève tes mains les deux
allez les deux vas-y plus ha allez fais
une petite garde fais une petite
garde rigolant tu rigoles tu peux pas
tire
longtemps les doigts tu tiens plus
longtemps encore
encore je suis fier de faire partie des
gens voyage c'est ma plus grande fierté
d'aille plus belle des VI aussi
Leon pour le plaisir de l'co je
crois égalité on' fout ça fraterné je
pense c'est la
liberté liberté c'est ça quandme
liberté
et ben là je vais je vais voir un combat
de coque c'est notre pass chez nous le
dimanche en
franceg
pasx méchant d'origine entrejà tout pe
ils ont de jours il battent c'est
vraiment dans le S c'est vraiment c'est
fait pour
ça
dy
il l'a touché là il
touché
touch as toujours connu ça toute ma vie
moi c'est c'est mon père déjà qui m'a
mis dedans mon père en faisait beaucoup
fa du commerce de coque il fais des
combats et tout et moi le fait que j'ai
grandi làdedans j'ai toujours
aimé tuécoutes Queen comme le
chanteur ça c'est des combats gentils
parce que des fois ils ont des petites
lames ou
quoi ah plus ça chauffe plus ça tape là
c'est c'est ça qui est
bien toucher tuis sur un coup comme ça
il peut le dénuquer il a le cardio là il
va
piquer fur je crois il est
fatigué on va arrêter on va leur donner
un peu
d'e pouroi lui c'est le Tyon Fury parce
que c'est le
meilleur tu sûr qu' va gagner ouais je
suis sûr Fury gagne tout le temps il a
jamais perdu celui qui remet un coup de
patte là il a gagné c'est le VUR il va y
aller il va y aller ah allez allez fure
qu'est-ce que tu fais
là allez donne ce que tu as là voilà il
a gagné ouais fur il a gagné c'est lui
Fury ah c'est vainqueur celui-là
il a perdu les sous vainqueurd sous il
faut que ça perdure parce que c'est
comme ça c'est dans notre sang c'est les
ancêtres faisaient déjà ça donc c'est
comme la bagarre c'est lescoques c'est
c'est comme le voyage c'est dans notre
sens on peut pas arrêter c'est pas
possible on est chez un ami à moi qui
est entraîneur de de chevaux de course
et du coup voilà deuxème paion deuxè
monde
les chevau la boxe il aime tout ça que
j'aimis
moi chaque commune autrefois dès qu'on
se mettait les caravanes les git ça y
est c'est des voleurs c'est c'est là les
voleurs de poule il y a toujours un
petit mot contre
nous on vient on te provoque on te lance
des coups il faut que tu te défend
pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bagarurand Mme la chance qu'on a
là c'est incroyable le matin il est
7h ça permet vraiment avec la box deder
la
tête décompresser de relâcher un peu la
pression
chez les gens du voyage déjà on a un peu
le dos large on est on est un peu
discriminé mon père il voulait pas que
je sois bagarreur mon père hors de
question la boxe c'est noble la boxe sur
un ring avec des gants avec un respect
de l'adversaire et la bagarre c'est
c'est la bagarre de cboy comme à
l'ancienne plein de champions aussi de
box mais après il faut être sérieux et
je dis pour ça il est il est carré a pas
d'alcool puis fait attention pour tout
300000 € il a 10 ans il a tout vu mais
il y a eu des grands boxeurs on a eu des
champions du monde chez nous mais pour
mon c'est le plus grand il a commencé
tout petit il a vaincu
ouis c'est mon
[Musique]
fils
ignons la
car on est grande et il est petit alors
on s'occupe de lui et on reste avec lui
quand tu es avec lui tu t'enuis
pas c'est la petite
mascotte c'est le seul garçon du coup B
c'est c'est le petit roi il a pas
compris tape dedans sans t'arrêter tape
dedans sans t'arrêter tape tape sans
t'arrêter encore encore encore encore
encore
encorearrête pas encore encore encore un
peu alle une dizaine tu un homme une
diaine tu un homme voilà c'est bon ton
cœur le
c ça c'est bon
ça ça tap ma mère ça c'est bon
ça le garçon c'est important pour moi
demain j'ai quel que soit ce problème
c'est le seul qui peut m'éper c'est le
seul que s'il m'arrive quelque chose si
je pars demain je m'en vais demain sa
mère elle fait comment font comment là
trois filles quatre filles avec la maman
ici tu vois un garçon c'est quand je dis
c'est l'héritier c'est c'est la relève
c'est les épaules de la
[Musique]
familleioio cardio cardio cardio cardio
cardio allez allez allez allez allez
encore non Tarrête attends moi peux le
faire moi je peux le faire les repas je
honnêtement c'est pas pour la bouffe
c'est plutôt pour être en famille VO
c'est d'être ensemble très important
surtout quand on est
seul les gens qu'on a besoin que ils ont
besoin de nous quand il un cou quand il
y a pas cou c'est un
noyau vraiment j'aimerais faire la
surprise de le monter en Angleterre voir
le combataille zone furrie ce serait
vraiment l'objectif c'est l'objectif du
moment
[Musique]
M
[Applaudissements]
ça là je travaille dur mais ça va payer
ça va payer le JG aussi c'est
sûr là je vais aller battre dans une
cité à Mont la jolie dans le 78 je me
suis inscrit dans les combats un peu
illégal pour dire de retrouver la
sensation de bagarre que j'avais quand
j'étais jeune
quoi il y en a beaucoup qui disent
pourquoi tu fais ça mais tu es fou tu
vas aller là-bas tu vas pas partir
vivant et Machin c'est l'amour du risque
moi ça que j'aime
vraiment
je vous explique la famille le frérot
kik va combattre contre un gitan ça va
être très très fort Gan vsond du
78 chez nous c'est la boxe qui
parle et de la
violence lui c'est encore plus un gitan
que le Gitan il vient trop loin il vient
de loin il a des Marou faites attention
que ça va ça va s'envoiller
fort minute de travailiv caravane gitan
j'ai toujours aimé parce que c'est des
bon hommes voilà c'est des bon hommes
ils aiment la famille ils sont bagarurs
ils font tout pour leur cause leur
bien-être et le bien-être de Laur
famille non ça à salumer tout
çaz mon
gar ça mon gars
quand il va venir à on va voir ce qui
c'est le patron si vient c'est que c'est
un bonhomme déjà après courageux déjà
ouais on félicite ça ça c'est
sûr et le reste fera sur le ring c'est
vrai voilà simpement pas peur de lui pas
du tout a pas de peur chez nous ça va
Conner fort la
[Musique]
famille
and now ladies and gentlemen to the
scale at this time the defending
champion makes his return to the UK here
is the undefated WC and lineal
heavyweight champion of the world the
Gpsy King
[Applaudissements]
Tyon
on making your return to the UK
defending your title 94,000 fans attend
us you have anything to say to your fans
here today watching it live and around
the world as
well you know what you guys are fucking
unbelievable come on
UK so happy to be back here fighting W
stadium and you people made it happen
you all made happen everyone of made it
happen and we're got to give you a
fucking real fight don't US we're going
to put a show on like no other before
it's going to be a war don't worry about
that
voà ce matin je su à 5h du matin là pour
aller combattre dans les cités à mon
Jie j'ai pas j'ai pas dormi beaucoup
j'ai dorm 4h cette nuit c'est quoi qui
te motive à faire 7 he de route la
bagarre on est presque frité on est
presque Faé dans la
[Applaudissements]
cité vraiment des couill là je suis tout
seul je viens avec ma femme
tranille et je viens me battre VO je
vais faire ce que j'ai à faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quoi
quand je suis en combat on dirait que
c'est plus moi qui boxe c'est une autre
personne qui prend le
dessus
[Applaudissements]
ser
[Musique]
lesz
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ou
[Applaudissements]
le 4è round faut qu'il soit décisif
[Musique]
cousin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon les gars les gars les gars je su
chez lui je pas
gag je suis chez lui je pas gagner for
for
ok les gars ils ont fait un super super
super
combat celui qui va repartir ce soir
avec la
ceinture après une
décision
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
unanimearsc pas non plus un combat du
championnat du monde mais pour moi c'est
quelque chose première ceinture ça donne
envie de continuer à
mort franchement FA plaisx
merci
continéit
merci c'est drapeau des voyageurs il y a
que moi je crois comme voyageur ici là
ce soir donc je suis seul je je ven avec
mes couilles
important pour les yeux de tout le monde
pour ma famille pour tout le monde
fallait que je gagne jusqu'au bout j'ai
rien lâché j'ai eu une victoire et tout
le monde l'a vu la ceinture c'est qu'il
a gagné il a gagné exactement ça veut
dire je lâche rien et je continuerai à
rien lâcher
quoi put some glue in it you know like
to do kids Messing
about oh here we
go my name St Egan and I'm the first
coach to train Tyson feels like my son
to me buuse I've known him that long
[Applaudissements]
it's our temple it's our church and it
used to be a church actually before we
took it
over there's me and Tyson Tyson was 18
then obviously that was me no Gray air
there look
ok no Ian that punch bag that was bought
especially for Tyson this is just for
Tyson to give him more movement you know
buuse he's big on
here you not got a lot of movement you
know what I mean you h the bag here BO
boom BO you step out that's easy but on
this bag
you and then you've got a move it's
coming after you so it's better for
movement you know so that's why movement
very good cuz that's what I worked on
movement uses reach uses reflexes the
Fains the heavyweights don't
do and when he was about 17 I did say
that to him I said the way you are mate
by the time you finished you change
people's perceptions of travelers say
what it feels from here you know and a
lot of people are scared to do that but
won't Ty say it as it is and if you
don't like it don't like Tyson now we're
going to the next
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
races don't
Toer and here
are
I call out the Prime Minister where are
you you need to
[Applaudissements]
come not
be it's not
acceptable that's why he a gypsy King
yeah he loves being a Gypsy's proud of
his heritage and all Gypsies
are
[Musique]
no du
NO the reason why she's walking back is
because the you got the whip
there
why
Right Round right Well Well I was born
in one of these and one of these wagons
yeah horses wagons that's why we
[Musique]
like Gpsy man always have chick right
down there sced me right down there to
chicken
did there is links and there's links all
over the world with traveling people all
over the world and starts from India
goes everywhereav people come from
everywhere it's a
ofury one of the best
Fighters he's Gypsy King and he always
will
so this is where youve situated yourself
yeah we're situated in a in a field in
the middle of nowhere as you can see um
Gypsy style you know well this is where
we store the wood where we like fires we
like fires and cook head jogs and
rabbits and and hairs and stuff PCH B
PCH yeah it has the uh the extra grip
handles for for holding the horses on
the
side
we're doing a little
cribs periscope the other day traer this
is where he P during the
night down have a fucking seat travelers
don't use the toilet in trailer no no
why not it's against the
law not going to have a shit in there
and then Cook your food on there like
one step away from the kitchen all right
and it wasn't bad you just got be
organed nothing bad about it I actually
had a better better time living in the
trail c'est la simplicité avant tout et
un vrai vrai g c'est ça on le suit et je
sais que demain même s'il y a un chinois
qui est gitant on le suivra aussi parce
que il est Giton c'est comme ça c'est
c'est jusqu'au bout jusqu'à jusqu'à la
mort j'ai pas fini
allô j'ai pas fini je te rappelle fini
interview moi demain même si avec la
boxe je serai millionnair milliardair et
tout ce qui
s'ens jamais je pourrais être comme les
grands champions à êre bling bling c'est
pas mon c'est pas mon truc moi rester
avec ma famille avoir le mode de vie
qu'on a ça pour rien n je le
changerai la forme
nickel je fais toujours le maximum pour
pas avoir de regret parce que c'est pas
après le combat que qu'il faut avoir des
regrets sinon on est un boxeur
malheureux donc je me donne à fond à
l'entraînement c'est qui qui veut
m'affronter ce soir to tu
m'ffronter je visualise comme si j'ai
mon futur adversaire en
face
il voudra m'arracher la
tête on a dû trouver un adversaire d'un
gros calibre 38 combats 30 victoires 25
par Ch je pense qu'ils veulent être le
tous les premiers à me battre et et et
très vite mais pour ça faut que faut
qu'il se livre de bonheur
[Applaudissements]
is je suis quand même challenger
officiel pour championnat
d'Europe dans CQ combats on sera
peut-être au championnat du
monde je veux laisser mon nom en fait
dans dans l'histoire de la boxe chez
chez les
gitans là on a une heure et qu de route
juste pour la pour lui pour la boxe du
coup voilà je prends mon temps sur
toutes mes les tournées de marché que
j'ai je prends une journée de la semaine
où je fais rien et elle est pour lui et
je fais toute cette route voilà pourquoi
pour qu'il a quelqu'un qui lui apprenne
qui Vasse pas comme nous nous on n pas
pu apprendre que ça soit je parle de moi
ce soit box écriture lecture je me suis
pas pas lou je lu donne tout ce que je
peux s'il est pas bon il arrête je mets
au vélo à la danse ce qu'il veut Mme ça
plaît s'il est pas bon je vais pas
perdre du temps ça ser à quoi tu es pas
bon tu es pas bon si tu es bon je fonce
pour
toi réveille-toi que tu sois pas endormi
quand tu arrives sur le r ma couille
allez réveille-toi
ma il faut faire ça ça l kick ça ça l
kick la bien bien l'oreille ok non non
mais doucement alle c'est parti boxer
allez pied point faut TR jamb et on se
déplace bouge après bouge ta tête faut
bouger sa tête les copains voilà et on
touche tro qure couilles on Bou on
déc il a Chud il va arrê Iland il a
chaud c'est
ça Chud al du Sporto
chaud cont je te fais un
bisou je ressens ma ma jeunesse à moi je
ressens mon mon
plaisir c'est important parce que le
petit il est valable c'est un bon gamin
il vaut mieux qu'on le mettre dans la
boxe qui a fumer le pétard ou qui aille
faire les
conneries dev jeîner tout seul je vais
essayer là je du gauche écoute-moi du
gauche avec qui dépl faut déplacer pour
pas que je touche coule voilà encore une
fois là tu es prêt direct li
noniki
yesei et si je veux je mets une
parcute c'est un truc de fou on a reçu
les places pour aller à Wembley pour la
finale du championnat du monde Tyon
fuurie c'est un truc de fou j'en ai
pleuré et je pleure pas comme ça ement
je ple pas moien parler je l' encore là
c'est tous les soirs tous les soirs en
plus il suteent dans mon lit pas pas
fais voir un peu ta F fais voir un
combat c'est là c'est là qu'on va aller
c'est il est comme un
fou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
force
[Musique]
le 1 décembre 2012
il a 2 an également une donation un
accueil extraordinaire pour
[Applaudissements]
J
[Musique]
alle
[Applaudissements]
courage super super 2
3 encore
encore c'est très bien tu as fait un
excellent travail souffle bien il faut
continuer comme ça tout le temps
[Applaudissements]
vigilant
tion de
[Applaudissements]
suite il s'accr c'est des
malin c'est des
fil
[Applaudissements]
bien toujours
toujours souffle
[Applaudissements]
biens
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez
voilà
vas-ys
[Applaudissements]
bienourh
vas-y
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à petit l'oiseau fait S
[Applaudissements]
essayer de vir un grand la famille
[Musique]
West
prière fois aussiin de chez nous
première fois dans un pays étranger
première fois où il parle pas français
prère fois il roule dans l'utre sens
prère fois le matin on mange
[Musique]
salé je téléphone et tu me prends en
photo ah vas-y alors allez
vas-y allô m ça
va alors tu as vu la reine d'Angleterre
quielle t'a parlé la maman ouais ben
c'est tout elle tout ça ça c'est sa g
royale
bizarre ils sont
sérieux il fait rigoler il fait rigoler
[Musique]
oui c'est bien très
bien pourquoi parce que
Ch
et comme ils sont comme ça j'ai
adoré un beau message pour Papou dis
gros message j'ai V chevas vu des
chevaux allez Papou à
bientôt
[Applaudissements]
the fight is
here fans are in for a real treat 94,000
people and we're going to rock and roll
on the night we're ready to throw down
and treat all to a hell of a bar Storm I
don't worry about
that
[Applaudissements]
le
coiffer je te
coiffe
allez tu es prêt ouais tu vas être le
plus beau ce
soir c'est le J
regardeind pas
comment il vouu Mme
costume boug que je gère mon
frèreou la maman incroyable tu vois
j'arver pas
regarde maintenant pour attacher ça tu
fais
comment pourquo devant la glace toujours
pour être beau toujours pourêre allez
[Applaudissements]
GL mettoi bien met-toi
bienon le Papou c'est Papou qui lui a
acheté ça cha combat des combat
il
familial
the
par
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi C
trou c'est
[Applaudissements]
plein
un momenton prépare le voyage à se
demander ce que ça allait
êtreas vu imagin comme
ça c'est énorme al imagine pour
luip de monde
impressionnéas jamais vu tout ça
tu es content
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bisous 95000 personnes qui sont là
95000 il pe beaucoup au Gipsy mais tu
vois qu' a pas que des des gens de
voyage ou des voyageurs des r tout ce
que tu
veux
[Musique]
toutes les nationalités écrit tous
jeipsy kingsy kingsy King aimé par tout
le monde tout le monde tout le monde
tout le
[Applaudissements]
monde
[Musique]
b
démarr c la
castagne une ambiance de malade les gars
c'est un truc de fou ça vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dit
igh in this ton
[Applaudissements]
L
c'est impressionnant il pour une
personne perc comment il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est reste reste en Angleterre maisre
caravane chez nous on retourne
chez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'espère que ça vous a plu un grand
merci à Cyril domanic et à toutes les
équipes qui ont parti iciper à la
réalisation de ce documentaire n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner à la chaîne de brut
et à mettre un like si vous avez aimé
cette vidéo et sur ce je vous dis à la
semaine prochaine